I finally had my first movie that I'd
written done and nobody knew and I spent
a year out of work
an entire an entire year I didn't get a
job and then I was offered a a property
that nobody else in town wanted to touch
because they were sure it was it was
suicide psycho too psycho too
so Universal
asked you to write it did you have a
pitch prepared for it no they just asked
you to write it I it was Richard
Franklin the director of the Australian
director who had the assignment and he
read a couple of screenplays of mine
and he really liked one called The
Crystal Tower and uh he had me in and we
talked about psycho too and I can't tell
you how or why but he chose me to to
write it now every nobody in town wanted
to do yeah how do you touch it's the
Masterpiece probably one of the best
horror movies in the history of uh
Cinema it is it's it's it's the
beginning oh yeah of the beginning of
horror really yeah yeah it's it's it's
the it's the first it's the first
slasher that we did you know it was so
much more than that but the uh and but
nobody everybody knew they were gonna
get ripped by the critics for having the
temerity I can't win it's a winless
situation and on top of that it was a
cable movie oh Communications looking
the credits you'll see it
and this was just as cable is coming in
and just as VHS is coming in
and uh
nobody wanted to do it but I I Richard
and I talked to you that I said the only
way you're going to get this made is a
feature film is if you get Tony Perkins
back to play Norman Bates
and Tony didn't want any part of it I
read that he didn't want any part of it
until he read your script well then so
what I had to do was try to figure out
how to make a piece of actors bait that
was so strong that one of the great
movie star actor would say I can't turn
it down and Tony blamed
psycho for ruining his career
because he had been a romantic lead
before that
Shenandoah Valley there were uh he'd
been a star on Broadway and look
Homeward Angel and then all of a sudden
he did psycho and everybody sees him as
that and that that really put her took
the took the edge off of uh being a
movie star and turned him more into a
character actor
so he had very
mixed feelings about it but what I wrote
was one of the great I thought one of
the great acting parts to come out in
the horror genre because Norman starts
out coming out of the mental institution
and he's saying and he's desperately
trying to hold on to his sanity and of
course the the the the the the the
relatives of his victims come back to
drive him mad
and at the end of the film
he kills his own mother and he's totally
raving mad so that is a hell of a
character Arc right it was it was a real
and it was a success it was the number
two movie Behind Return of the Jedi that
year that's right and that really put
you on the map didn't it that made me
that made you this guy did The
Impossible yes because without psycho 2
being a success they probably wouldn't
have made any more